[Musique]
parole léotar Philippe musique Servin
Philippe voici leur jazz contintine
drôle de
[Musique]
Caroline un soir celle que j'ai croisé
n'était pas vraiment une
louve mais plutôt une femme
lou au cœur mordu aux yeux
brisés qui me prit comme un dieu tombé
cherchant un ventre qui n couvre
comme on veut qu'une fille
s'ouvre et rende au corps ce qui le
trouble au moment qu'on est plus fidèle
qu'à la dernière
rencontrée une
femme n'importe
laquelle qui tienne encore la nuit
couchée et pour qui on sera S et blême
au matin la de
soi-même
[Musique]
ma drôle de
Valentine ma copine de famille ma
camarade derade où on mangeait des BRI à
la vra sa
caillou qui avait le goû à de ce qu'on
va trop
aimer tous les deux loin des nôtres sous
le volcan des
autres je me souviens j'étais
fou d'ailleurs je me souviens de
tout qu'on s'aimait
[Musique]
surtout
fatalement défait de nous tout d'un coup
on coupait à tout on voyait cintiller au
bout l'extrémité intime en
nous toi amère magique louche tu avais
un goût d'acier
tendre moi un flingue froid dans la
bouche
[Musique]
suffit de pas tirer pour
s'entendre suffit de se frotter pour
apprendre l'amour et ses millions de
couches on s'est couché pour se
comprendre de la terre au ciel du cœur
au
ventre si on peut dire l'amour toujours
on peut baiser
[Musique]
l'éternité ma drôle de
Caroline ma victoire et
Marine mon ami de la nuit mon intime
ennemi au regard
étoilé ma source auou mer ma vie vue de
la mer mon inverse
astronaute sous le volcan des
autres je me souviens j'étais
fou
d'ailleurs je me souviens de tout qu'on
s'aimait
[Musique]
surtout
ce que dévorait ma paresse tu me l'as
pris pour me
l'offrir me donner le don de
souffrir tu m'as forcé à la faiblesse
d'aimer l'amour en
mourir sous tes douloureuses caresses la
cruauté de ta
tendresse et tu endormais le sommeil et
tu réchauffais le soleil et m'apprenais
par
l'oubli lequel de nous deux s'est enfu
de l'autre un de ces jours où j'ai
compris qu'il faut d'abord s'aimer
soi-même pour faire l'amour à la
[Musique]
vie ma drôle de
cocaïne ma pensée ma blessure
mon absente qui dure endormie sous les
ruines des rêves
réservés ma rose mon épine mon intense
amour mon cœur gros mon cœur lourd de
temps de temps
passé je n'ai rien
déserté je me souvien tout tu
sais
surtout
simis drôle de Caroline